[Music]
so today's an exciting day for me
because we are at the launch of our
amazing breakfast club here at hologram
P burger at Planet Hollywood so this is
our amazing super talented super dynamic
chef and this breakfast menu is a
corporation together and also that that
twist in terms of people like fast
but super delicious even with the most
amazing french toast which was your idea
so it's taken from it almost like a
sticky toffee pudding but done with
authentic little bottoms caramelized and
looking good - that's going to slow down
the process I'd touch the seasoning and
then my fresh chives in there
fold that in
and a secret this sauce humble dairy is
literally as soft as heels come off look
at that
your pull-up a spatula and then seizing
it last minute senior too early it's
gonna go great
[Music]
radio
come on
so it comes believe it I'm not
Koga for the last vegan we did a house
made a plant-based sausage which we
blended with my spices a little some
scrambled tofu to mimic the soft
scrambled egg smaller arugula small
and then that vegan bun as well on
they're so soft scrambled last vegan
this is the delicious brunch burger so
they start off with the most amazing
countless shallots almost like a little
sort of onion jam then we got a peaceful
pate
Christmas nation look at that come on
seriously guys working out that 4:00 in
the morning
[Music]
thank you free incredible Turkish soft
scrambled Las Vegas as in vegan mass
vegan and entirely
[Applause]
right and welcome to behind the scenes
but this is a very special moment here
is a unique Wellington on on top is one
million because we're about to announce
our first millionth customer in just
over two years now they don't know that
we know who they are
come join me and witness this historic
moment health fiction Caesars Palace
this is a big one let's go
[Applause]
I'm so excited to be here but tonight is
a extra special evening because we have
just celebrated one millionth customer
the good news is they are here and they
have no idea they are without surprise
them will you join me and help celebrate
our one millionth customer because we're
about to approach them and wish them an
amazing dinner please
[Applause]
it's you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you